L'Histoire racontée par
des chaussettes
C'est très marrant
eh
eeeeeeh !
Aïeuh ! mais t'es con ou quoi ?
Mais pourquoi tu réponds pas ?
Comment je peux savoir que tu me parles à moi ?
On est 500 ici
Ok
On joue aux devinettes ?
Non
Qu'est ce que c'est ça ?
J'ai dis non
Eh bien moi non plus, il fait trop noir !
(rires)
CHUCHOTEZ MOINS FORT !!!
c'est lui chef il arrête pas
Je t'ai pas demandé ton avis Poucavios
Pardon.
C'est plus fort que moi.
On attaque quand chef ?
On sort quand la nuit tombe.
Elle tombe quand ?
Tous les jours. J'en sais rien quand elle tombe.
Mais on est arrivé à midi et on est là depuis 20 minutes !
Si vous continuez de parler, dans une heure on est grillés,
embrochés
et on finit en sandwich grec !
Parce que nos ennemis
sont des GRECS !
Ok
D'accord
Pas la peine de prendre la mouche.
La.... MOUCHE !
Tais-toi, toi !
Mais euh papa !
Aaaah
Voilà pourquoi il est là, lui
Quoi ?
Qui ? Moi ?
Oui toi.
Non toi.
- Non toi.
- Pas moi
- Si toi là
- Non toi.
- Non toi là.
- Pas moi.
- C'est toi.
- Arrête.
- Lui - Lui - Non oui moi - Oui toi
- J'suis pas sûr de... - Non c'est moi - P'tête c'est toi
- J'pense que...
- Vraiment, il fait trop tout noir.
GIFLEZ-VOUS TOUS !
Hein ?
Je trouve pas celui qui a parlé...
Alors, giflez-vous tous.
Mais... on...
On ne peut pas... tous...
Tous ? ça fait tellement trop de...
Dépêchez-vous !
Sinon j'vais commencer à mettre des p'tits coups de glaive au hasard dans le vide !
Et comme il fait tout noir, ça sera pas de ma faute si je vous plante tous !
*Clap* - Aïe ! *Clap* -Ouh ! *Clap* - Oh ! *Clap* - Mmh !
GIFLEZ MOINS FORT !
*en chuchotant* *Clap* - Oula !- Aïe ! *Clap* -Ouh ! - Stop !*Clap* - Oh ! *Clap* - Roh !
Voilà. Et maintenant, fermez-là.
ça va être long.
Mais tu sais pourquoi
on veut leur faire la guerre en fait ?
Non, j'sais pas.
J'crois qu'ils ont capturé une de nos femmes.
J'ai entendu à un moment le roi d'en face il a dit:
Hélène, deux qui la tiennent, un qui l'empile, trois qui la volent, un truc comme ça...
AAAH !
J'AI BIEN PIPI !
Génial ! T'as trouvé les toilettes !
Non.
Ah...
Bien sûr...
OOOOH Œdipe !
Si t'étais pas mon fils...
OOOOH !
PAPA CHEF !
Et c'est ainsi
que le siège...
- CONCLUEZ MOINS FORT !
*en chuchotant* Et c'est ainsi
que le siège dans le cheval de Troie avant l'attaque se déroula.
*en chuchotant* En tout cas d'après des chaussettes.